bro we made a place introduced dip a
pizza joint how'd you do it it's called
makers Pizza in Toronto and the first
time we went in there Jermaine and I
ordered a pie and I'm looking at the
menu I'm like and then I'll just I don't
see it but I'll just take three Ranch
dips and turn around they say oh no no
we don't have dips what the [__]
our pizza don't need it you're actually
threatening them yeah
just a local little restaurant opens up
some of the locals come by they're like
do you have dip they're like nah we
don't do dip they're like
you just hear that
looks like that Western
and then just hear the [__] the Spurs
spin around the floor yeah
her job boys don't have dip
whole town scrambler
foreign